share your your mom is still with this
yes this it's not funny but I do think a
brilliant bit of advice that you should
share is her five-year rule if it
doesn't matter in five years it doesn't
matter isn't that bad happens you gotta
think will I care about this right so I
you know and it always helps me it
always comes in handy no I read that and
I just thought bass pretties actually
your genius yeah nice really really good
and I wonder did she come up with that
thinking when you were a teenager cuz
you were quite a wild child I would say
alright i was wilder when i was nine
years old than I ever was as a teenager
I ran away from home I stole a horse I
jumped on a freighter and kept going
until my girlfriend started crying for
her mother oh how did you get back I
called my mother yeah your mother loves
you but daughter but she is actually
sort of a fan as well it's not quite
that it's um no she is a goodness right
here so my one day my mom came to set on
the skull was set and I was getting this
thing called cyber scanned which is
where you stand in this kind of loads of
cameras and they kind of take your form
and put you into a computer and make a
toy or a some sort of merchandise or
you'll face on a cushion and so I do
often do this and I come back and mums
like I've made a great friend
brilliant lovely excellent and just
likes the merchandise you know director
of all of Star Wars something I'm like
wow impressive before I know it what
comes in the post is loads of cushions
my face on it
my mama gets to see it a fair amount but
it's not enough so blown away just the
beginning it was like the pre
merchandise not even the real stuff is
out yet and my mom has all of it and but
doesn't have a door yet so what is this
in your flat or her house okay so
basically she's not be really funny if I
came home and it was everywhere in my
actual bedroom and then oh and then oh
my kid if we found the photo but it's
not like that now
so Emily are your kids how are they with
it well I think um I mean my youngest my
two year old has a sort of attention
span of a fly so she watches the trailer
but hazel who's almost five has seen it
and just absolutely loved it and sort of
wants to talk about it all the time now
and yeah it was really weird if your
mother's Mary Poppins I do think she see
I think she just thinks it's normal
she's like well that's what this is what
Sunny's mummy does and this is what my
mummy does you know it's just sort of
like quite conversational for her
is it gonna help or hinder discipline at
home Oh hinder really yeah I think so
because she knows she already knows I
can't fly she's like what
but she did ask me to do the voice the
other day just out of nowhere because
she was quite sort of impassive watching
the film just thought it didn't just
sort of didn't reveal much of what she
felt and then the other day she goes do
your she's American of course sounds
American she good she good she goes do
your Mary Poppins voice and I go
spit-spot and off we go and she goes
[Applause]
where I say to the to the dolphin no no
not yet and now the two of them go no
not yet your home has been lovely to
fans that you'll be very nice you go see
it yeah very good David you're a big fan
but someone else in your family is also
a very big fan yes
my mum's a big fan and we were in a
restaurant at the River Cafe about
probably about seven years ago my mum
had drunk a bit too much and she
suddenly felt a bit ill and I led her
outside to the table as a new assassin
one of the tables and she's stopped dead
and I had to sort of drag her like you
would a donkey on a beach away so
excited to see you well how ill was she
otherwise you've got to let me see if I
can figure out who she is
hmm I can I can see her already she's
blushing she's Miley look at her look at
her here you go
come here darling
[Applause]
he's a good mama's boy you're not proud
of your lad back 42 million books of it
these days he just might win an Oscar
[Applause]
was he a good boy
no come on off the record was he a good
boy
sometimes Oh showing off now because
you've got Tom about your daughter
wanting to make you cry oh we were
talking about what I do for a living and
and I was explaining how I try to make
my I just make-believe like she does
when she plays and she's like just can
you make yourself laugh and I see it she
goes can you make yourself cry and I
said yeah and she goes do it you gotta
give me a story so we made up a story
and I've done it before for people about
sriracha I don't want to go back into
this grandma okay what is this Roger
plant is um they're shutting it down
because the fumes kind of go into the
community and yeah but I've done this
this is redundant on the couch when
you've been toured shows the Oscars
you've all taken your parents which is
that seems you know dad for for if you
all do the same Ryan your mom she I mean
I'm sure she likes meeting celebrities
but isn't it the gift room is really her
thing she enjoys I don't want to help my
mom like this
I will tell a funny story about that
picture though which is that my mom was
convinced that year by her friend that
beehives were gonna be all the rage he
didn't have a beehive you'd feel
embarrassed and it turned out to be the
opposite it was a natural hair vibe but
and my mom sat in front of Rachel Weis
and her hair was so high that Rachel had
to keep sinking in a chair and I didn't
know what to do because I was you know I
didn't wanted to have a nice night so I
I didn't know Meryl Streep but she was
sitting next to me and I said in a
commercial break - would you would you
mind just telling my mom you like her
hair and she was like I got this and
then the commercial when she goes do you
know I wish I was gonna do a beehive and
I wish I had my mom yeah
because I'm gonna your mother does she
pretend to not know the famous people or
does she just get a bit overexcited
approximately are she well I mean that
when the first time I went to the Golden
Globes just says let's bring that back
around that was this year we were
sitting next to now it's you know not as
fun to talk about but it we were talking
from sitting next to Angelina Jolie and
Brad Pitt and she was just asking
multiple questions like if they had kids
maybe what's it like I mean I had no
idea the whole time you take your dad
the year of American sniper yeah
no here's the things I think it is a
lovely thing to take your parent to the
Oscars but once the ceremony's over
don't you just want to ditch them like
is that you just do the party
no he came along till 5:00 in the am
really dancing a guy series house next
to John Travolta and now he was great
and emotional and sort of just wept
throughout the whole thing yeah dance
with Prince really you just totally
taught me
I like it could we go one better come
you go one better you and Matt both took
your mom's mom's wish only fueled rumors
of our sexuality
[Laughter]
we take our moms who look great in that
in that picture my mom my mom they do a
weird thing where like if the Oscars
they put because they'd have to rehearse
where the shots are gonna be and so on a
television business thing don't worry
about it
they put big name placards of where it's
total say instead of high cuz it just
says Jack Nicholson you know then
they'll say like Ryan Gosling whatever
and my mom was obsessed by that and went
around taking pictures
[Music]